percy
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement mes chers collègues vous
allez tout le monde va rentrer et je
vous demandais au regard de l'actualité
et de la gravité de celle ci de bien
vouloir respecter
l'orateur lorsqu'il va s'exprimer et le
gouvernement lorsqu'il aura la charge de
répondre l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions gouvernement premier orateur
monsieur yves fromion pour le groupe
l'est républicain
oui monsieur le président merci je
voudrais simplement dire que le groupe
républicain s'associent tout
particulièrement dans sa totalité
avec beaucoup d'émotion à l'hommage que
vous avez rendu à nos amis tunisiens
ma question s'adresse à monsieur
mobiliser la défense monsieur lui disent
tu dans son discours prononcé au congrès
de versailles le 16 novembre le
président de la république a annoncé au
détour d'une phrase que la déflation
d'effectifs prévues dans la deuxième
mouture de votre loi de programmation
militaire
tout juste votées au en juin dernier ne
serait pas mise en oeuvre cet lp m
devient donc caduque
l'opposition tout en soulignant cette
façon singulière de traiter le travail
parlementaire ne versera pas une larme
sur cette défunte lpm à laquelle elle
s'est opposée comme d'ailleurs à sa
mouture initiale en décembre 2013
quand voulons tout de même que pour vous
qui vous faisiez fort d'exécuter la
programmation militaire avec une rigueur
jamais égalée par vos prédécesseurs
le coup est rude il l'est d'autant plus
qu'en renonçant à la quasi totalité de
son projet de déflation des effectifs de
la défense françois hollande revient
j'appelle votre attention mes chers
collègues françois hollande revient au
format de notre armée décidée en 2009
par nicolas sarkozy le président de la
république pouvait-il rendre un hommage
plus éclatant à son prédécesseur à la
justesse de son jugement à sa lucidité
sur les exigences de sécurité
alors monsieur le ministre une nouvelle
loi de programmation militaire s'avère
indispensable
nous en aurons donc eu trois pour le
prix d'une espérons qu'il ne s'agit pas
de soldes et notre défense disons cela
je fais référence à l'information qui
circule dans les états majors selon
laquelle le report de charges
c'est-à-dire les impayés s'élèverait à 4
milliards d'euros en fin de lpm il
s'agit d'un dérapage inédit monsieur oui
je vous demande donc de nous faire le
point sur le devenir de la programmation
militaire remise en cause pour la
deuxième fois par le président de la
république
la parole est à monsieur jean yves le
drian ministre de la défense monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs le
député monsieur le député yves fromion
merci de cette question vous rappeler
avec justesse que le parlement vient de
terminer l'examen et le vote de
l'actualisation de loi de programmation
militaire
ce vote ayant été acquis à une large
majorité dépassant la simple majorité
politique d'aujourd'hui je voudrais vous
le rappeler au cas où cela vous aurait
échappé monsieur fromion
et on peut le comprendre puisque cette
actualisation pour la première fois
permet un abondement financier très
significatif des crédits affectés au
budget de la défense augmentation qui ne
s'était pas produit depuis de très
nombreuses années et pour la première
fois aussi en cours de loi de
programmation on voit les effectifs
augmentent et singulièrement plus que
l'actualisation prévoit 11 mille postes
supplémentaires singulièrement dans la
force opérationnelle t rès dans la cyber
sécurité dans le renseignement
mais depuis le président de la
république a annoncé deux mesures
importantes
la première c'est le renoncement à toute
déflation au delà de 2016 puisque le
budget de 2016 prévoit déjà une
augmentation significative des effectifs
de la défense et cela se traduira par
10000 postes supplémentaires en 2017
2018 2019 est par ailleurs un engagement
de réflexion à la fois sur la réserve et
sur les ailes sur la garde
nationale tout cela peut mériter des
amendements et des observations et des
inflexions sur la loi de programmation
militaire mais je vais vous dire qu'il
faut aller au delà et sous l'autorité du
président de la république le premier
ministre va être amené dans les semaines
qui viennent à faire une proposition de
réflexion globale sur l'ensemble des
questions de sécurité à la fois de
sécurité extérieure et de sécurité
intérieure à la fois sur le terrorisme
sur les relations avec nos partenaires
sur les relations européennes de votre
question va au delà de la sympathie
rogations